if you are living in a black and white
world where everything is either good or
bad with no Shades of Gray and you feel
sad and empty with an intense fear of
being left alone then you might be
experiencing what's known as
[Music]
BPD borderline personality disorder is a
mental health condition characterized by
a distorted self-image along with
difficulties regulating emotions and
maintaining relationships it affects
around 1 to 2% of all
adults like all mental health disorders
it is considered to be on a spectrum
meaning that it can manifest in all
sorts of ways ranging from regular
outbursts of anger to severe forms of
self
harm the causes of BPD aren't fully
understood also because it goes hand
inand with addiction other Mental Health
health issues and eating disorders
environmental factors such as a
childhood of neglect and abuse seem to
play a role but so may
genetics since science has not yet been
able to find any biological evidence to
diagnose mental disorders we have to
turn to symptoms to see if someone may
have BPD to illustrate this meet
Alex Alex is a 20-year-old college boy
who is always been sensitive but lately
also feels isolated and extremely
emotional he experiences five symptoms
that are often associated with the
condition Alex experiences rapid changes
in
self-identity in a single day he can go
from feeling Godlike to feeling
worthless and in a crisis he changes
from one personality to another this is
when he goes through moments of
dissociation where he feels feels
detached from his body with no sense of
self at all Alex has what's known as a
distorted
self-image he experiences intense and
unstable emotions the smallest setbacks
can send his mind spiraling out of
control and make him end friendships in
an instant every emotion he feels he
feels intensely Joy becomes Euphoria and
sadness turns into depression this emot
roller coaster leaves him exhausted that
is when he
dissociates he struggles with
impulsiveness when talking to his
friends Alex often feels misunderstood
with close to no self-control he starts
shouting or lashing out later he feels
ashamed to cope he eats does drugs or
turns violent often against
himself he has an intense fear of
Abandonment when his girlfriend cancels
their date at the last minute he breaks
up with her and a few minutes later
bombards her with texts asking for
forgiveness he is constantly worried she
will leave him and demands impossibly
high standards of
reassurance all of this leads to
unstable relationships when Alex fears
he will be abandoned he hurts his
friends for no obvious Reason by pushing
others away he thinks he can avoid being
pushed away himself he later feels
ashamed and Promises to
change after an intense period of
paranoia Alex wants to drop out of
college which at this point is pretty
much the only stable thing left in his
life it's then that his best friend asks
him to seek
help when Alex speaks to a professional
he learns about BPD and that the typical
treatments are forms of of psychotherapy
like CBT cognitive behavioral therapy
DBT dialectical behavioral therapy or
MBT mentalization-based
therapy the psychiatrist also explains
that in some cases patients take
medication such as mood stabilizers this
can be important as over 50% of
adolescent that attempt to take their
lives are diagnosed with borderline
personality disorder
understanding his condition is a relief
at least he knows he's not
alone what do you think what can we do
to help people with BPD please share
your thoughts or your own experiences
with this condition in the comments
[Music]
below
if you found this helpful check out our
other videos and subscribe if you want
to support our work join us on